Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 30th, 2015 what's going on? How,
um,
I'm not doing shit.
It's Sunday night sitting here with my
fucking pit bull and I'm watching a,
it's halftime of the Patriots Broncos.
That's what I'm,
that's what I'm recording this.
What?
Bop Bop bop that data.
You know what sucks about the fucking NFL?
I never thought I would say this.
This fucking parody think I swear to God,
every,
any team can beat any team. See it die
like a thousand deaths every Sunday.
Remember back in the day, you know, if
your team was good, you had those teams.
You could just kick the shit
out of four of them a year.
It just seems every week.
Now you're in a fucking dog fight.
Okay.
14 to seven. Now they're going into the
half. It's starting to snow out there.
These orange crush of
starting to feel confident.
Okay,
hightower got hurt. Yeah.
What are you going to do?
You know what I noticed
watching Sunday night football,
you know when they have the,
uh, the little thing, I'm sorry,
I got the TV on in the background.
I can't believe they're redoing the Wiz.
Yeah.
You know. Did you guys ever see
the original one? I swear to God.
Is it me or is it fucking nine hours long?
It takes them like three hours before
they even get to Nipsey Russell.
Okay,
come on in. Ease on down. Why don't you
fucking run down the road? I'm sorry.
That's such a bad joke when
it's too fucking long. Um,
who the fuck pitch to Redo that thing?
I don't even get and why do you put it
out now? That's not a holiday movie.
Okay.
Why don't they just keep them
like the old, what's do you know?
I'm taping Rudolph the red nose.
Rob Babo Rudolph the red nose reindeer.
That classic one from um,
well it would have back in the fucking
day. I'm going to watch it, you know,
Tuesday night it comes on.
Get myself into the
fucking holiday spirit.
I can't have the TV on do a podcast cause
I'm just keep talking about you guys
want to watch TV with me.
I just saw this new ray Liotta um,
Jennifer Lopez movie or TV show. I don't
know what it was. It was just coming out,
I thought was gonna be one of those
commercials were Ray Liotta just stares at
somebody because they're
not drinking vodka.
I just want the other person to be
like frank. No, I make the, I'm sorry.
I love fucking Goodfellas,
but this is my drink.
Okay.
What's going on with you man? What's,
what's with the fucking looks relaxed.
I get it.
You can kick the shit out of me.
You know,
he's just laughing at their fucking
manhood. He's disgusted with him.
He's just dusted.
It's actually an amazing piece of
acting because he never says anything.
He just fucking looks at him and he's
just see, just see the generational gap.
He can just see him going.
Your entire generation is
a bunch of fucking pussies.
Okay.
Just with one fuck. He just gives
him that one. Fuck it, look,
and next thing you know,
of course they got the guy sitting
over there with like an umbrella drink.
I don't think I've ever sat in a bar
in anybody's ever fucking looked at me
cause what I was drinking,
I guess I've gotten shit for it.
Okay.
You know, but that was just back when I
lived in the Boston area. They'll come on,
you fucking do was shot.
Um,
God driving into, we're
all driving, only arrest,
making fucking excuses. Um,
anyway, so you know, and that,
that fucking horrific Sunday
night football song comes on,
you know the little cutie pie there in
her glitter outfit cause she's in show
Biz. Right. So you got to
have some glitter on. It's
all this special effects shit.
Um,
I don't know if it's me or what is,
isn't that song just a complete
fucking rip off of Joan jets?
I hate myself for loving you.
Yeah.
When they get to the whole
fucking, you know, I,
I love my for watching
football, isn't it? How it goes.
I think I know what they say.
I always fast forward through it.
I've never liked that song.
I liked it back when it was an orchestra.
You know when you had
somebody like John Williams,
you had some great composer come up with
a piece of music that I could actually
move you emotionally.
And then somewhere along the line they
went to Hank Williams jr and he took his
hit song. All my rowdy friends
are coming over tonight,
you know, don't blame Hank
Williams jr it's not his fault.
Okay?
His Dad obviously banged somebody
who had no musical talent whatsoever.
And so the best Hank Williams jr could
ever be is half Hank Williams Sr.
But you know, sometimes you
get a little more, you know,
you get a little more one than the other.
So rather than him singing and what
the fuck did Hank Williams sick?
You cheat and heart my loan. Some truck.
I don't know what the fuck he saying,
but all I know is that guy
like drank himself to death,
but he was only like, wow,
I got to look this up.
How fucking old was that guy?
That guy looks like he's fucking 60
yeah,
he drank himself to death. [inaudible] I
gotta look this up. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
You know, this is the kind
of, this is what happens.
This is what happens when you fucker just
run your God damn mouth. Hank Williams,
Hank Williams, Hank that he was,
he was the original frank the tank,
but he was Hank 1923 to 1953
he was fucking 30 years old.
Okay.
You know, he, that's a, you
know, as, as sad as that.
Is that as a hell of an accomplishment
to drink yourself to death by 30 I mean
anybody can, Oh d am I that, you know,
but I mean to literally to put it in the
fucking hours that the amount of hours
that it to drink yourself to
death and only 30 years. I mean,
you've got to figure the guy didn't
have his first shot of booze.
Okay.
I'll even give out. Get say 13 he
had his first fucking drink. A Bose.
Yeah.
And within 17 years guys fucking dead.
Okay.
That's amazing.
I remember a long time ago watching
some fucking show or something that was
saying the body was actually
designed to live 150 years,
optimal conditions,
you know,
basically if they treated
you like a fucking classic
car that had been at a body
off restoration and they just sort of
floated you around and never drove you or
anything like that. Right. Like you could
live, you know, breathing perfect air,
eating perfectly and all that.
You'd live for 150 years. Um,
which that made sense to me because
every time when those people used to come
and give the cancer
talks about cigarettes,
it'd be like every time you
smoke a cigarette you take
five minutes off of your
life,
there's 20 cigarettes in a pack.
So that's a lie.
That's a hundred minutes.
So you just took almost two hours of
your life away. So I was sitting there,
you know, doing my dumb
Masco. Well, Jesus Christ,
you'd be fucking dead by the time you 30
cause I was counting down from like 80
I guess their count down for one 50 or
maybe they just lying and they're trying
to scare the shit out of you and they
don't think some freckled cutting.
The crowd's going to try to actually do
some math. I don't know. All I'm saying.
Okay.
As you got to give it up to Hank Williams,
you know,
okay.
Drinking himself to death, you
know. Ah, you know the first third,
the first third is cirrhosis is fucking
fun. After a while it's not fun anymore,
but you know, a lot of things
aren't fun after awhile, you know?
Okay.
Being a parent isn't fun.
After a while you see it on their faces.
Once they get to ask the little bundle
of joy once he's done say acute cute
things, once they'd done
being cute, you know,
like they step on an ant and they say,
hey wait, what? Go Guy dead it identical.
Yeah,
go. Did you say I taste, she
just said I did it. Killed it.
Oh,
that's adorable.
All right.
The little things kids say once they get
past that and they start rolling their
fucking eyes. Yeah. You
know, you're just like, yeah,
I'm fucking over this shit.
That's right.
Parenting is like cirrhosis of the liver.
Look at Bob Costas with this fucking
smart looking coat and his goddamn scarf
guy always look sharp. You gotta
give it up to them. Um, my,
I'm the only person who wins too when
they talked about what was wrong with
Peyton Manning's foot plantar Fisher
writers, which I've actually had,
um, from improper technique playing
drums. I didn't know how to get,
I was trying to do those John bottom
triplet fucking things from good times,
bad times. And I think I was just using
my big toe to try and make it happen.
So it was arching my foot.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I woke up the next day. I thought someone
was stabbing in the foot, but, uh,
Peyton actually it's basically this, I
don't even know what it is. I had it.
I don't even know what the fuck it is.
I thought it was a tendon that
runs along the Archie of thought.
I Dunno where to after I saw the drawing
then I didn't know what the fuck it was.
But it goes from your heel to like,
uh,
like when you get your Bunyan there,
you know if you get hammertoes
stop hammertoes dual due to too.
If you get a hammer toes, right.
That part that sticks out. Anyways,
the part near the heel they say
is tearing away from the bone.
What the fuck I'm done.
I am fucking done.
At that point I might,
well part of my body is
tearing away from the bone.
I just stopped doing standup.
If my fucking arm from leaning on the mic
stead is something in my elbow started
Terry, that I would just be a
podcast and that would be it.
My voice would crack and I would cry.
So that looks like we're
going to be losing Peyton
manning and Coby Bryan in the
same fucking year. Two monsters of
their game. Do you guys see kobies poem?
My wife read it to me. I actually, even
as a Celtics fan, I was a little sad.
Then I also, I had to chuckle
that he wrote this whole poem,
this whole Ode to basketball and,
and not once did he ever mentioned coaches
or teammates and I was kinda thinking
like, you know what ads? That's why
he never passed the ball dead. He,
he's still one of the greats,
but Jesus Christ.
How about a shout out to fucking shack?
At least his ass, you know, remember
that. How does my ass taste? I'm sorry.
Well let, let's, let's get, let's get
back. Let's get back on track here.
What was I talking about? I was
talking about Plantar Fisher. Itis is,
I would know, I was
talking about how, um, the,
the hook of that Thursday night fucking
song, the Sunday night football song,
they got to get you into it,
right?
Cause you're not into you cause
you're not into football evidently.
So they've got to have some lay
come out in a little sparkly dress,
throw a couple of looks to
the camera. Like, you know
what? I blow you fewer here.
I'd fucking blow.
Yeah.
She's got to give you those looks
Thursday night football is his mouth tits,
right? They do. That can break
free of the things that you do.
It's the same fucking sock
and full life of me. You know,
I think Joan Jett or is she had to
go after the fucking NFL. Why not?
They went after Tom Brady.
Why can't they go after fucking Joan jet?
Do you know?
I got an a big argument with this fucking
friend of mine right through right now.
I think he said can't talk,
but he just was, you know,
he was being, he was being at what?
I've never run into a whiny giant fan.
New York giant fan. I love giant fans.
They never bitched. They never whine.
They just fucking beat my team. I
got to respect that. He was fucking,
he was still whining about the giants
losing to the Patriots two weeks ago.
It's like, dude, you went to and Oh and
the fucking super bowl against this.
Why don't give a fuck about a game
in November? You know who won?
They could wield,
she wouldn't look good.
Cause when you go to go to [inaudible]
they wouldn't cared. But he caught it.
Yeah, I agree with you. Okay. I thought
Dez Bryant caught that fucking ball.
I don't understand what you got to fucking
do these days for them to call it a
catch. It's a weird fucking rule. Okay.
So he started going in on how the
Patriots cheat and I'll let fucking whiny
horse shit.
And he tried to say that the Patriots win.
This is the best one I've heard so far.
The Patriots where 90% of coin tosses,
which I think that's the number I always
pull out of my ass when I want to win
an argument. That's the percentage
I always go with 90%. Okay.
If 90% of people out there with rarely
fucking blue, blue, blue, right.
So he tried to tell me that
90% of the fucking time we,
when the coin toss it's like, okay,
so what are we doing there? Yeah.
Are we somehow sneaking a fucking
different quarter in there? Like, it's,
it's just unfucking.
And he continued on with the whole,
the Patriots watched the rams
final fucking a walkthrough
before the super bowl,
even though the ESPN detracted it and
said that was a complete horse shit lie.
Of course they'd attracted at
1230 in the morning. You know,
they talked about it for five years at
nine o'clock in the morning on sports
center. And then when they find out
that they were perpetuating a lie,
they then know, oh, sorry about
that. It fucking 1230. So,
um, I dunno, I finally
got him to come around.
I finally got him to come around.
It's just like, look, okay,
if you want to see the guilty of
gamesmanship, absolutely do they fucking,
you know, try to get away with shit
if they could get away with it. Yeah,
but so does everybody. They just don't
fucking, when all the Superbowls,
you know,
it's unfucking believable what other teams
have done and there's like no fucking
problem. Like, I'll tell you right now
that fucking, do you guys see that,
that Redskins play
where, uh, Kirk cousins,
they hike the ball and the ball flew
out of his fucking hands and he asks the
Ref way,
did you get this ball?
Cause he thought there was
something slick on it and they go,
you got it from your own sideline.
If that happened during a patriots game
and the other quarterback said that we
would have lost a draft pick somehow
they would have fucking put his you.
Is it possible that maybe date day Greece
the fucking bled. Somebody sneak over,
dress like a red skin and
grease stop the balls.
Um, you know what I mean? I don't, I,
I've gone through this a Zillion fucking
times, but uh, you know, I, I don't know.
It's unbelievable that,
that piece of shit,
Jim or say and that piece of Shit fucking,
uh,
I can't remember his name, man. Eric Mann.
Jeanie have affectively
tarred and feathered. They,
the Patriots that will,
that will be brought up for them
for the rest of fucking time.
Air Pressure in stealing signs is
what they're fucking guilty of, right.
That's it.
These are the teams have to fucking
deep edge tested positive for steroids.
They're building stadiums that make their
fucking fan base sound loud is fucking
hilarious. Oh, that's the
pumping fucking crowd noise.
It added five, five. Don't worry
about it. Don't worry about it.
Jesus fucking Christ. We still signs
for one fucking game. One game.
It was illegal.
Then
they did it every game.
Okay,
unreal. I'll have to have that
debate for the rest of the time.
It was only illegal for that one
game that we did it and got caught.
If we did it the year before, the year
before, it wasn't fucking illegal.
Then I'll use stupid cuts out there.
Who think all you have to do is just film
the other coach and then you know what
they're going to do. You
dumb fuck. She got a,
you'd have to take that and
line it up with their plays.
Watch it at halftime and then try
to memorize as much as you can.
If you're lucky, maybe on two plays,
you know what the fuck they're doing.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
the teams sit there and they watch game
film every fucking week looking at their
formations and all of that shit.
How was that legal?
He couldn't do that back in
the fucking thirties right? He
fucking just sitting there. I guess
you could. If you get what camera?
Some guy in those fucking jockey parents
and just sit there role in the film.
How was watching game film legal?
That's gear considered.
Then you're a good student,
but if you try to steal their signs,
then you're a cunt. I don't, I
don't get it. I don't get it,
but I'm never going to defend that.
The Patriots don't try to fucking
bend the rules in their favor,
but I won't go so far as to say that
everybody else in the league doesn't also
fucking do it. This whole fucking
horse, you know what they sound like?
They sound like Republicans when they
talk about America, when they go,
America was founded on,
everybody's got a shut and they
completely ignored genocide and slavery.
Right. That's what other football
fence sound like to me when they,
when they try to act like we're the only
ones who fucking Dick around with the
rules. Oh Jesus Christ.
He just landed on Brady,
the Brady rule in effect,
personal foul hit, and Tom Brady,
I love that man. He's got a cute
little bud, 15 yards first down.
I love it. I love it. I love it.
It's called the Brady rule. You know,
even still, it's the money rule.
They call it the Brady rule.
That actually suggests that the NFL on
some fucking level gives a fuck about a
Tom Brady. If they don't, they give
a fuck about the money he makes.
You know what I mean? It's like
fucking Lance Armstrong. All right.
After all the bullshit after
he gets fucking cod there,
everybody gets on their high horse.
That's disgusting.
That's not what the Tour de France
is about and all that fucking shit.
Let me ask you this. All those constant
made, all of that fucking when he met,
when he wants seven in a row and people
who didn't give a fuck about bike racing,
tuned in and watched, and they could
charge more money for advertising. Okay.
During that whole time,
did they give the money back?
All the fucking money they made all
those owners that made all that money off
all those fucking guys doing steroids,
you know,
hitting a ball over the fucking God
damn freeway made all that money. Oh,
we're going to clean up the game.
Oh yeah,
you're going to give away all that
dirty money. You made you fucking cons.
Like you didn't know they
were doing roids that shitty.
If you manage to an Applebee's in,
in half of your staff was on
steroids when you wouldn't,
you wouldn't fucking notice at
some point when you walk in,
when you go in and to go get a
fresh sack of fucking potatoes,
you wouldn't walk in on somebody
inject and somebody else in the fucking
buttocks. Just out of just
being there every fucking day.
You know what's going on.
I ever tell you that time when
I used to work at that fucking
is holding all fucking day and they let
it got Brady Dank doesn't end itself.
Love fell you motherfucker.
Okay.
We got away with holding on
that one. Jesus Christ. Anyways,
I used to work in this fucking, um,
I used to work in this restaurant.
It was called the sable cafe and
Cary North Carolina back in like 87,
88.
Uh,
why did I just say that now I'm going
to say all this fucking horrific shit
about it was a fun job.
And uh,
there was some activities that were going
on in the back room who gives a fuck?
It was almost 30 years ago anyway,
so I worked in this fucking place and um,
I used to work on a mesquite
grill and I had this big chef hat,
like I knew what the fuck I was doing
and the place was gradually going out of
business. One of the managers
had a major cocaine program,
but a lot of people did. It
was the 80s. It wasn't really,
it was just becoming a problem, you
know? That's right around was cocaine,
the big lie, you know what I mean? So
this guy used to steal from the registry,
do a little fucking toot.
Right. And you know,
you know if the fucking the guy,
if that guy fucking running shit
yeah
is on drugs and I mean it just trickles
statement guys sent in the example.
So you know,
I remember I used to work like the fucking
dinner shift one night and it's just
fancy fucking restaurant and buy fancy.
I mean this carpeting,
this cloth napkins and they had
a giant fish tank. All right.
That was fancy for fucking
Cary, North Carolina, you know,
and it was fucking asshole. So he's giving
me shit for being a Yankee, you know,
affect carry back then stood for
concentrated area of relocated Yankees.
That's what these say like, you know,
you don't, you don't care. Stands for,
you know what that stands for. I
know buddy. What does it stand for?
Concentrated area. Relocated. Yank.
I fucking hate the draw. Play.
Yukon's has the draw play ever will.
It's never fucking
worked. The draw play, eh.
Okay. May, it must've worked at some
point. Keep running the fucking thing.
I think that's what you've just decided
that you're going to punt. It'd be like,
all right, you know what? Let's just not
give the ball over right here. Let's just,
uh, you know, just wait
a second. It never,
it never fucking works.
It's weird how the draw play doesn't work,
but somebody fucking basically
doing the same thing.
But if they go out for a pass, it always
works or it works more times than not.
You know what I mean? Like, so did
the, did the uh, delayed screened
right
when you got the line gap rackers
coming up the gap. Ah, Jesus Christ.
What are we doing? Yeah. Fucking crazy.
Anyways, I gotta be honest with
you, with all the interest we got,
I think if we replay Carolina Panthers
right now, um, the only reason we,
if we would win would be we would just
out coach him out of fucking experience.
But I think Carolina, it looks like
they look like world beaters to me.
MMM.
I Dunno.
How fucked up is it that the red skins
are fucking five and six and they're in
first place.
You know what I mean?
Like I think seven and nine
could win that division.
Yeah.
You know,
I'll tell you what's going to be brutal
is watching the New York media drive,
Tom Kauflan out of town. That's going
to be fucking unreal. Like he doesn't,
not a coach.
You know,
it's not his problem that one of his
best defensive players maimed himself.
You know what I mean? That whole fucking
thing he had to deal with. I mean,
I don't know. I don't, I mean, the
fucking guy's a winner, man. He,
he came to BC immediately, turned
it around after the, the, the,
the Doug Flutie hangover. All of a
sudden we became, we were winners again.
I have to pick now left.
He went to Jacksonville.
He always got the Jacksonville
Jaguars to the fucking super bowl.
He fucking goes to the
Goddamn New York giants.
They went to super bowls beating
the undefeated patriots. 18 and off
guy has one fucking bed. I guarantee
it. They're going to fucking stay.
Going to send them out of town is,
you know,
one of my buddies thinks this
because of his wind burned face.
I've never seen a guy who needs
fucking lotion more in my life.
Like I think that that's his next move
before he, if he gets run out of town,
you know, and he just needs a break from
football. They should do that thing,
you know, like if you go and
bald and they just go, Eh,
not only the fucking Douche bag and the
commercial, I'm also a client. Right.
He should do that with like fucking,
uh,
whatever face lotion, whatever
the fuck eco, whatever.
How do you get that red shit off of his,
he's got,
he's unbelieved the guys getting these
guys wind burn in like September.
It's like,
it's like he loved,
he always looks like he just got
done competing in like America's cup.
You know what I mean?
At least come out with a little knock.
Zima and you know is right. I don't
want you guys to thinking like pill.
You're just running your fucking
Yap here. How about a break? I'll,
I haven't gotten the advertising or the
fucking, the questions yet for this week,
so I'm just fucking filibuster in here
trying to get through this shit. Um,
hey did I did, I mentioned that I went,
oh, I told you guys not on Thursday.
I went to the, uh, the king's
Blackhawks game. And, um,
um, what, what, uh, the, the
highest level hockey I've seen
in so long, it was unreal.
Like the whole first period.
He just seemed like they were feeling
each other out to see what they were going
to do and, and just that,
the whole fucking thing,
every fucking line, every deep
defensive unit that goal tenders,
all of that shit. It just, it was
incredible the way that they play.
Do you know that was, there was
only two penalties. The whole,
it was two penalties in the
first period. That was it. Um,
Chicago went up to nothing and then the
king score two and the third and then
came back and won in overtime by the way,
three on three.
Even if you fucking hate hockey,
there's,
there's nothing to hate about
three on three hockey and overtime.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Just end to end action every five seconds.
It seemed like he was seeing a two
on one or a breakaway and um, ah,
the lovely Nia. Everybody look
at you linger in over there.
I actually heard Al Michaels tonight.
Talk about the three on three hockey.
Are you leaving? Are you going to come
here? You got to go see creed. Yeah.
Nia is like one of the only black
people ever into that band. No.
Yeah,
don't you like them?
What are they saying about [inaudible]
crash on the Brown chair and,
and he got you to having a
shot. Okay, good. No, not,
not created the band. What did
creep sanctuary, the moving,
I don't know if you can sing a creed song.
Oh, I'll take you out for an ice cream.
Okay.
Can you take me
hi.
Oh, that's right. I
wasn't bad. Can you take,
I don't know what he said.
Hey,
is that like power rock?
Is that considered power rock?
Those kind of bands were like,
the lead singer is just like,
like just like this really,
anytime they say power
associated with music,
there's no power in it. Okay. Come here,
come here. And it says, who says you? Yes.
Just me and my dumb opinion. Ah,
you are fucking over me today.
Are they playing in Boston?
The Patriots now they're playing a Denver.
It always rains. No, no. Sorry. Um, yes.
I'm going to go see Korean. Are you
coming? Are you going to be done?
I don't have the advertising of the
questions yet, so no, look at Clio.
Look how cute she is.
She's actually an exhausted by,
took her on a long hike today.
Yeah,
I think we definitely need
to start feeding her more
cause he exercise her like
you're just like an athlete. Yeah, because
she didn't put on fucking 10 pounds.
I did. Yeah, me too.
You know what I'm going to try to do in
December? What's that, honey? Oh God,
I pissed me off today. I got to
tell the story. I got this. The Nia.
Nia hates when I make fart noises.
Like if I'm singing and I dunno,
I just go home if I just do that.
I hate when people do that in general.
It's so,
I don't like it because I don't like
bathroom, a toilet humor. Like, I just,
I think it's so gross. So she hates it.
So of course, Duh. What am I going to do?
So I'm singing along to the radio and
I just keep making fart noises in the
matter. She gets, the funnier it
is to me. And I keep thinking,
don't do this because we had a wonderful
afternoon. This is going to ruin it.
And I just, there was so much
fun. I had to keep doing it. Yeah.
And you kept doing it while
it Natto Dude, dude, dude,
dude, dude, dude, dude, I
have to go to the movies.
No,
you know there's something wrong with the,
if you don't think of fart noises funny,
I can see if I actually fired and he had
to deal with the death that came out of
me. Right. No, nothing is wrong with me.
You have the maturity of a 12 year old
and it's like you can't just let someone
enjoy their day without doing
something irritating. It's true.
You like to irritate people.
Especially me.
Admitted,
admitted.
I have no idea what
you're talking about it.
I just wanted to take my lovely wife
out to lunch. You did take maps lunch.
It was very nice.
That was great.
Okay.
I don't want to stay away
if such a problem with that.
I'll, you know what, I'm,
I will make an effort to stop doing it.
Can you take me high or
near old person has to say,
I'll make an effort not to make
fart noises. Like what? Seriously.
I'm a fucking clown. That's what I do
for a living. What do you want from me?
Not to make fart noises.
You're better than that bill.
I'll fuck you for a psychology.
I'm not know how much you hate that.
Say you're better than that.
Terrific. All right. I'm going. Hey,
have you noticed the Bronco's
quarterback is like eight feet tall?
Are you talking to me?
Yeah. Why would I? Okay.
Well you can notice as somebody
who's tall can do that.
Weird how fucking tall he is. I don't
know which one you're referring to.
I want to see him riding a
tank like Michael Dukakis,
just to see how much of his torso
comes out of that fucking hole.
Remember what he did. The
you were too young when they,
when he ran for president,
he was running for president. He was
doing fine and then he drove a tank. Well,
you to drive a tank.
They just had him stick his
fucking head out the running.
I remember when he was running for,
even though I was young and I remember
his wife drank like rubbing alcohol.
Then Shame Kitty Katie.
Oh Yeah, you need to caucus. Yeah.
It top three dumbest reasons I ever saw
anybody not be able to run for president
or lose it.
Is Dukakis sticking his head
out that fucking manhole.
That's what it looked like. He was his,
it was his fault. Can eyebrows. That's,
that's what screwed up
Gary Hart getting fucking in trouble for
banging is a that fucking broad on the
boat. I mean, that's what you
get a boat for. Right? All right,
you're losing me. I'm losing Ya. And
then third was when Howard Dean, when
an enemy, we were just like, I fucked
that guy. He got a little excited.
He was like a restaurant. I thought
that was weird. I got to Carolina.
I'm leaving goodbye. It
was an unfortunate, no,
it was an unfortunate moment.
Hey Ann, a joy the movie.
I wish I was going to go see
it. Email. What time it is.
I texted all the information.
Do you mean literally what time it is
you saying that and like a black way?
Like you know what time it is?
Jesus. She hates me. Um, all right.
That's the first half of the podcast.
I have to wait for the
advertising and all that shit.
So it's not going to mean shit to you.
I'm just going to hit pause and when I
come back I'm going to read a little bit
of advertising. Uh, it's 14 to seven.
The nine foot quarterback drops back.
He throws it down and that's
a first down for the Broncos.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Look at the size of them.
Okay.
It's not even any snow on the
top of his helmet. I mean a guy,
he's up up the star cloud.
Sorry,
what's his name?
Osweiler.
Okay.
Do you don't need it took me to this
fucking German bar and I had the best God
damn fucking brought.
And I got one of those giant beer
steins like a fucking asshole. Um,
but whatever it starts tomorrow, man,
I gotta turn this shit around, right?
I've actually, I didn't lose the
weight. Nice fucking play. Um,
I didn't, sorry. I didn't,
uh, I didn't lose the weight
I wanted to lose, but I just,
I stayed the same, which is pretty
good for fucking Thanksgiving week.
I still worked out every day, buddy.
You know, I made a bunch of pies.
I had to eat them. You know, what the
fuck was I supposed to do? So, um,
anyways, what I want to do
is, uh, six days a week,
I'm actually going to go to the gym
and I'm going to get on that fucking
elliptical for an hour. I'm going to do
it six days a week throughout December.
That's the promise that
I'm making to myself.
And as you can tell by
the tone of my voice,
I'm not even remotely thrilled by it,
but I refuse to go right back to the
fucking fat ass cunt fucking weight that I
was. Uh, the pies are done.
Most of our Thanksgiving food is
done. So I can go back to my, uh,
yeah,
my thrilling way of eating healthy.
I can't believe I fucking die.
What the why?
I can't believe I did
this to myself again.
You know what the one good thing I do
have is I haven't had a cigar in 15 days.
That's pretty good. So I want to
be that guy or fucking, you know,
once a twice a month I'll have a cigar.
It'd be a special moment.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Oh God. I just pictured Caitlyn
Jenner and a bubble bath.
My wife showed me that fucking picture
and I freaked out. I wasn't ready for it,
you know, just showing
it. I was just saying, Oh
yes.
Woo.
Okay.
There you go. Yeah. With your
stupid Movember mustache.
We know people are dying of cancer.
Kill fucking shave that off.
Um, anyway, so I'm just
literally stalling,
waiting for this shit to fucking
come in here. I got to, uh, let me,
let me hit pause you.
I'm gonna hit pause and I'm going
to fucking find out where the were,
where ever I'm going to get to the
bottom of this and now when I come back,
you guys are going to get to listen
to me read out loud. All right.
Ooh.
Okay.
All right.
By the magic there with the magic of the
pause button on back like a half hour
away,
it's still 14 to seven to
beginning of the fourth quarter,
but now it's time for me to read
out loud with that APP. Me undies.
Mandy's.
No more sweaty testicles.
But who to to Mandy's Biondi ga
when you're fucking chest to Kohl's.
And why did I say testicles?
Goddammit is you fucking
take it is nice and dry.
You fucking cut my dad a
patriots. Hey, cut. Oh,
go fuck yourself.
No flavor.
Mandy's Mian d you'll feel like
your balls are made out of the lore.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Um, all right. When you look
good, you feel great everybody.
It's a cliche because it's true.
Mandy's understands this and that's why
they designed underwear specifically for
you and your nut bag,
and it makes you look and feel fantastic.
Wasn't a fucking running
back or caught that number.
38 who the hell said can't read. He's
got the dreadlocks over his name there.
Please include all of the following.
Shut the fuck up.
I'll read anything you write me undies
is the mold is made from modal, modal,
modal fabric.
That's twice the softest cotton kind
of fuck you measure that. I don't know.
What do you rub it up against?
Some scientists face. All right,
and here's the other side.
Oh, I liked that one better.
How much better on twice as
better Yada. Ah, that's twice.
The soft is whatever underwear you're
wearing right now. Balmy undies.
Swear to God. If you cross
and uncross your legs, you're
gonna fucking blow alone.
That's how fucking sausage.
This underwear is just tickling you.
Fucking God. Damn p holder. I mean,
Andy says tons of colors and styles.
Of course they do. And the only place to
get matching pairs from men and women.
That Jesus, how fucking awful
a relationship are you in?
If you fucking underwear
matches your fucking wife,
why don't you wear her underwear?
You fucking pussy.
They even a new design every month I
wear whatever free pair they give me a
Goddamn,
but my nuts have never felt better.
Plus we know that paying
for shipping sucks.
[inaudible] has removed that
from the equation. Yeah,
by rolling it all into one price.
I hate when they say shit like this.
All orders in the U S and Canada
shipped for free me undies.
Even as a money back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you keep it for free. Why
would you? You don't love it.
You'll literally have nothing to lose.
So fucking go check it out. All right.
Dollar Shave Club, everybody
those shape club, uh,
stop shaving with an old razor.
It's gross.
You know,
once you treat yourself,
why are you torturing yourself with the
gross old blade week after we give her
thought about that? Why do you do
it? Cause it's a pain in the ass.
It cost a zillion dollars. They've
got to unlock it from the case, right?
You don't want to shell out 20 bucks
for a pack of new ones basically.
And it's a pain in the ass even
as to go to the fucking story.
Even if they were priced what they were
supposed to price be priced at. Right.
Set of a sentence works. I don't
know. Let's get to the point here.
Dollar Shave club.com has revolutionized
the way that men shave with dollar
shave club.
You can shave with a fresh blade is
often as you want because they deliver a
whole sleeve of amazing razors
for just a few bucks a month.
I'm eating so bad right now. I thought
they were going to say sleeve of cookies.
I got excited there for a minute. Are
they Oreos? Uh, their razors are so good.
Millions of guys have joined.
Even the billion dollar razor,
a razor corporations are freaking out,
but instead of lowering
their bloated prices,
you know what these assholes did
that trying to fool you into milk,
milking the same blade for an entire
month. And that's gross. It's disgusting.
And it's ruining your face.
They've price gouged us for long enough.
Never go back to squeezing weeks and
weeks and weeks of shaves out of a
disgusting rusty blade.
Joined the dollar shave club revolution
and use a fresh blade. Whatever you want.
It feels amazing and it's a third
of the price. It's incredible.
Join the millions of others who
figured out the smarter way to shave.
Join Dollar Shave club now by going
to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar high
dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] all
right.
M V t m MVMT watches.
This is the last read.
Oh No, there's two more.
We got to do all these cause I
don't have the questions. Yeah. Uh,
thanks to movement watches for
their sponsorship of this podcast.
They sent some watches and blank.
Please share your thoughts on the watches
here. Well, I haven't gotten them yet.
I always turned down this shit, by the
way. You know what I mean? When they, hey,
I'm gonna send you some fucking peanuts
and velvet underwear. It's like, I don't,
I don't want that shit. I got too much
shit. I got too much shit. All right.
I got like at 9,000 fucking drumming
things that I'm never going to use.
Just filling up my fucking office.
The last thing I need, you know,
I'm sure they're great. You know you
got an investor's. Isn't that enough?
I've got to walk around wearing
it. Interception. Fuck. All right.
Mvt Empty Wad. Let's read this
again. Mvmt watches, so let me,
I'm going to be a team player in this one.
MVMT watches everybody.
Let me do it where you can edit it so
they won't hear this part. MVMT watches,
thanks to movement watches for
their sponsorship of this podcast.
They sent me over some watches.
Oh my God,
I can't believe how well they tell time.
They feel great am I will risk too.
Does me undies make the watch band?
They got to my wrist feels
as good as my balls tried.
Check them out.
It was this little crowdfunded brand
that is revolutionizing the watch game.
Oh snap. They started to get a
lot of press from Gq. Playboy.
Hypebeast askmen said they are the
hottest watch company on the market.
What the Hell is hypebeast?
Uh,
they're all about this idea that high
quality doesn't have to break the bank and
they actually deliver probably why
they have over a million social media
followers.
You there?
They got some horse showing her
tits while she wears the watch.
That's another way to get, that's where
to get another million right there, right.
Anyways, quality crafted watches
starting at just $95. You know something.
If he tried to get a watch like
this at a department store,
you'd be spending at
least four to 500 bucks.
This style is minimalistic.
It's clean and it's sleek.
You know what it makes you
look like you read. Okay,
this is one of these smartwatches. All
right, so as long as you keep you stupid,
Yap, shut. Nobody's going to notice.
She might get the fucking job anyway.
She can wear this thing at
the office during the day
or out at the bars at night.
All right.
It's new and it's an all day.
Where as opposed to those other watches,
you know,
he does wear it for like 20 minutes. You
guys, I got to take it off. I don't know.
It's itchy. Um, all right. Call to action.
I'm going to help you get your style
on point, man. It's a checkout em,
the empty watches.com. That's
Michael Victor, Michael,
a tangle.
Uh,
we're hooking you up with
15% off your entire purchase.
That's M v empty.
Michael Victor,
Michael Thomas,
watches.com/birth.
I don't know why I get blocked on the
t word. Um, all right. The last one,
mercifully. Mercifully. Was that
a fumble patriot? Say they got it.
Patriots like it.
I don't see the refs flipping out.
He's pleading his case and ain't going
to happen. It ain't going to happen.
Is a fat referee right there.
Bet He's warm.
He's got a built in fucking ski Parker
right around his fucking his chest,
right? Oh No. Oh No. We fumbled the ball.
We fumbled the ball and then
the Broncos recovered it.
Oh God. Damn you. God Damn you.
How dare you do that?
Wearing Steve Grogan's old number.
I think the Broncos get this ball.
Oh, you fucking cock. You know,
I just realized you guys
already know what happens.
Okay?
You know I'm sitting around acting
like this suspense here. Oh, Bella,
check doesn't look happy.
21 to seven we had these guys
put away the ball coming back.
40 60 Ted,
you let this eight foot quarterback right
back in or the 40 yard at 36 yard line,
eight foot quarterback drops back
to pass. He throws it down. Hell,
the guy fucking drops it.
Okay.
Came right through a cloud. All
right, stamps.com everybody.
We know what the holidays here.
You have time to go to the post office.
You don't have time. Sorry. Do you go
to the post office traffic parking.
It's going to be packed with everyone.
Mailing holiday gifts, some packages,
so do what I do.
All right.
You stamps.com instead with stamps.com
you can avoid all the hassles, man.
I go into the post office
during the busy holiday season,
everything you would do at the post
office you can do right from your desk.
So there's no reason to go anymore. Well
what can I do on my desk? I don't get it.
Well you can buy and print official US
postage using your own computer printer,
um,
print postage for any letter or
package the incident you needed.
Then the mailman picks it up
so it's easy and convenient.
I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters, whatever.
I whore myself out after my shows.
And you know what? You should too.
You should make a poster.
You should do a show.
Just send them out freight right
from your own desk right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name, birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer
that includes postage and a digital scale.
Said I'll wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
you click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage. It got and get typed in,
bar that stamps.com enter
birth. All right, there we go.
And I am out of fucking, oh,
for fuck's sakes. Tackle a guy.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh God damn it. This fucking parody wine
or we got a lot of injuries and shit,
but Jesus Christ is fucking parodies.
Killing me.
Okay.
They're killing me, killing me. So the
other night I went to a bar, surprise,
surprise after, um, after the,
uh, the king's Blackhawks game,
um, I took the subway back. I
love taking the subway out here,
you know what I mean?
And it's like a real subway now.
Like there's all kinds of fucking
vandalism on it and shit. I remember when,
you know, when I first moved out
here in 2007, you went down there.
It was just like,
okay,
you went down that subway.
It's like, wow, this is what
okay.
The world would look like if there was
a like a massive plague. Yeah, yeah.
Let them turn the corner and get a first
down and a touchdown. There you go.
Great defense guys. Where to go?
Yeah. Fucking Christ second. Um,
anyways,
I was thinking like,
this is must be what the world's going
to be like after a giant play gets right.
And then we start all over again and
we still know how to do shit right.
We still have some reason the
scientists fucking survive. Oh fuck.
Some other scientists survived.
That would be the ultimate thing if
the scientist survives. So you like,
you had the same amount of
people on the planet that, um,
that existed, you know, when we were
just running around in caves and shit.
MMM.
But you have all that, that new technology
then that, that would be perfect. Right?
And,
but you need ditch diggers too.
We fuck is going to plow the
street and pave the roads.
Come on miss the extra point.
You fucking cut 21 to 14. Um,
am I the only patriots fan that actually
thinks it's a good thing to, um,
to maybe lose a game and go into the
playoffs and like the panthers be
undefeated? Oh yeah, they'll a little
always. I'm just thinking, you know,
get a little less attention.
Just one year.
I would love to be treated like the
Indianapolis Colts. You know what I mean?
Well,
your owner could literally be abusing
drugs and fucking around with everyone,
you know? And nobody gives
a shit heavy. Tremendous.
Just live in that quiet time out there.
Wouldn't that be nice?
All I think it would be.
You know,
I also think it'd be nice if I could
get some fucking questions over here.
I don't know what else I'm
supposed to do with myself. Well,
what am I up to here for
45 fucking minutes and me
running my Yap and trying to
read out loud. This is getting
ridiculous. You guys won't listen to me.
Send a text. This is pathetic. You know,
I'm gonna start my fucking Christmas
shopping. I know. I was going to say,
so I fucking came back on the, I know
I'm all over the place. Fuck you.
It's how my brain works.
So I'm on the fucking subway.
I get off and I meet Jay
law had it this fucking bar.
And it's just one of these cool fucking
bars they're not a lot of people know
about. But enough people know
about that. It stays open.
You could fuck a chill out in there,
man. He could have a good time.
And it was perfect.
It was a perfect old man fucking bar.
I apologize for yawning if I'm
making you tired at work. Um,
and everything's going good.
And then out of nowhere,
this cool bar,
they started having karaoke and all these
fucking nerds are going up there and
just go and just go in full out singing,
horrific saying it, dancing,
just absolutely awful.
Just a horrible display of
communication was going on.
And it was annoying the shit out of me
cause I just wanted a peanut quiet place.
Ah, drinking. Why am I young? And all of
the places drinking of fucking, you know,
a bear or something. I just want to be a
nice quiet fucking place. Right. And um,
the fucking
halfway through them singing
and dance is everything.
I actually fucking tap la head and I go,
I go look at them, look at them,
law ahead, look at them. I go,
that's what's heckling
you on Twitter right now.
Look at, I'm trying to dance. Look at
these fucking animals. Trying to sing.
Look at them. These are the
people. These are the, that blog.
These are the people that get offended.
Oh, look at colors. What? That mail,
Michael's bald rock and the scarves.
I never understand why
they have the scar or they,
are they inside or are they outside?
They always make them look like
they got the window open. I had to,
I need to take a nap. What the fuck
just happened? You know what it is.
I'm getting sleepy waiting
for these fucking rage to
come over here. Um, you know,
I'm interviewing Pete Corey Ellie this
week, uh, for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast where I check in on you. And uh,
he has a new special out on showtime.
I believe.
This is one of my favorite comics that,
uh, not enough people know about. Um,
great storyteller. And I've known him.
I've known this guy for 20 fucking years.
Back when we used to, um, I worked
in New York comedy club together,
late night spots and all that.
Who the fuck is that guy?
Brady keeps throwing to the Anti Gronk.
Who is that guy?
Yeah.
Oh yeah. We get a pass interference. Ah,
he comes up first. Loss of the year. Oh,
well what the fuck are you going
to do anyways? Um, you know what?
I'm gonna hit pause again. I'm going to
wait for these things. I swear to God.
This is, this is the most fucked
up podcast I've ever done.
I'm going to wait for these,
these,
I'm coming back reading people going
to prepare your right now. All right,
I'll be back. Well, you know,
if the technology help you
back in a second, right?
Yeah.
All right, I'm back. I don't know if
that's right word that I say. All right.
I'm back because it didn't seem like I
left with the fucking editing. Right.
Shut up bill. We get it. He hit pause. Um,
I can't find it. I
guess. I don't remember.
My reads aren't coming through this week,
so I'm just going to fucking pick some
shit out here as I go from old email.
Somebody sent me something because I
mentioned that I went to chipotle and they
had all these signs on the wall about how,
Hey, we don't put any shit in our food,
which may be fucking weirded
out. Like, well, you shouldn't,
but I guess so many people do. I
don't know. So I thought, you know,
made them seem shady to me. Right? By the
way, it's 2117 at this point in my world.
All for fuck sakes. He gotta
catch that is behind him though.
Um, anyways. Yeah. It says, Hey, bill,
just want to drop you a
line about chipotle a,
which you've mentioned
on Thursdays podcast.
Check out this recent article in La Times.
Chipotle is being harassed by a bogus
consumer watchdog group that is actually
funded by restaurant alcohol,
tobacco in energy companies.
They are spending millions of dollars
harassed and companies that do or say
anything, which goes against the
interest of their clients. Chipotle,
a stance against antibiotics in meat
has apparently incurred their wrath.
Uh, this firm is engaged in a very
public ad campaign smearing chipotle ace.
So I think probably this
think this probably has
something to do with all of the
sides you saw in chipotle a the other day
touting their product and what they do
differently. Thanks for the
podcast. Go Fuck Yourself.
So I clicked on the link there and um,
and it says, why is it nonprofit shill
for business interest attacking chipotle?
So as the US Department of Health,
and you mean human services says that if
you're being pushed around by a bully,
walk away and stay away.
Don't fight backs.
Chipola has taken this message to heart.
Evidently they're not fighting these guys.
Chris Arnold is spokesman
for the Burrito chain,
told me Chipola has no plans to tangle
with the food industry front group that
has run a series of ads critical
of the company's health claims.
Uh, the guy says, Chris says
this is a smear campaign,
but we've chosen to take
the high road position.
Most recent ad appeared last week
in the New York Post. It said,
chipolte lay is scaring the
public and tricking people.
And to thinking that change
meat is healthier because
it's quote antibiotic Free
Blahblahblahblah so
allegedly this is just some,
this is a group that's pretending to
be a watchdog group, but it's actually,
you know,
a spokesman for probably corporations that
put antibiotics in their fucking food.
Um,
okay.
And all of this other shit.
Jesus,
Tom Brady is just acting
like a fucking lunatic one.
Are they going to throw a flag and a guy?
I know he's got seniority,
but even as a patriots fan,
what is, yeah, he's, you know,
he's fucking flipping out.
Okay.
Yeah, he's losing his cool.
Okay. Like Tommy, Tommy, get
the fuck outta here. Okay.
You're the face of the Goddamn leak.
We,
we can't give you a fucking
Gronk seems frustrated. Oh,
are the Broncos cheating? God, it's
all right. That's okay. Are they,
are they doing little fucking underhanded
tech days to get an advantage?
That's okay. You're in
Denver. It's fine. It's fine.
No cheating. No underhanded shit there.
Tom Brady, throw a date out of fucking,
what the fuck?
Boy,
this doesn't seem like it's our night now.
It does it 2117.
Now it's fourth and 15. I don't like
it. I'm already drinking already. Good.
I heard you got a beer here. So anyways,
these fucking guys, I guess. Um,
I don't understand how
these groups are legal.
Just had been around for years where,
okay,
you can put together a fake group.
Like Rick Berman,
executive director of the
center acknowledged that the
organization is funded by
part, by food and beverages company. Um,
he declined to name any of the
contributors and he and the guy goes,
it doesn't matter who pays as long as
what I'm saying is truthful and I'm
telling the truth. What a crock
of shit. Um, you know what?
I guess so who knows?
I don't even know what to believe now.
I guess now I'll go to fucking Chipola.
Yeah,
I don't fucking know. I, oh,
what is it a belief? I mean,
if you're going to have fucking,
you don't understand this genetically
altered salmon now. Like why?
Like why were we allowed to vote on that?
Why don't they put that to the people?
Why is that the fucking
center? Oh, that's right.
Cause they got them all paid
off right now. It works.
Jesus Christ. Do I have to hit pause
again? I do got to find another letter.
This is like fucking a,
this is like what podcasting in the 18
hundreds must've been that been like,
right. I got a bad feeling. We're
going to lose his fucking game.
I built to the Patriots. Help you pay
your bills. Oh, but I mean, you know.
Okay.
Did the football team of my city
be back in a minute? All right,
so I guess there's going to
be no reads this weekend.
I don't know what to fucking tell you.
I don't know where the fuck they are,
but I'm not waiting around all night.
All right. There's four minutes left.
We had off the ball and a fucking Taggle
is again right at the line of scrimmage.
Um, some of my drum teacher got
me into tears for fears this week.
I couldn't stand them in the 80s. I
just hated the guy's face. You know,
he, the way he sort of launched his
face at the fucking camera as he sang.
Well,
go to Ma.
Right. And I just couldn't
get past if fucking face.
So first day out.
So he fucking
three and a half minutes left,
come on Patriots, hang in there,
get a fork and vehicle vehicle over there.
Um,
that's still won't help us that way.
I feel go put out up by fucking seven
points. I like it. So anyways, um,
he goes, listen to this, uh, tears for
fears and I was like, oh, like, oh my God.
Tears for fears. Every, every body
wants to rule the world and fight.
You know how many times I've
heard that fucking song?
Like now I don't mind tears for fears
because it reminds me of the 80s when I
was young, had a full head of hair my
whole life in front of me. You know,
you know, my pants were all puffy.
I was lifting weights every day,
but only the upper body.
Okay.
The way you supposed to, oh
no, to Gronk just get hurt.
And he took it. Oh No. Oh No.
Oh No, no. Oh No. Ah,
fuck
dude.
Everybody who's even remotely
good on the team, his heart now,
except Brady. I shouldn't
have just said that. Oh Jesus.
Oh, they just went to commercial.
Just went black. Ah, fuck. Anyways.
Um, so he says, listen to this
tears for fears. You know,
everybody wants to rule the world.
I might get the fuck, you know,
so I'm listening to it for years.
I never heard what was going
on with the high hat. You know,
the guy's playing triplets, but he's,
he's playing them in groups of two.
He accents every other one.
Listen to it.
I always thought was just dumped
on the talk. I thought it was sad.
I didn't know like the high
I was going to get, get, get,
get, get, get, get, get, get,
get right. Only drummers understand what
I'm talking about, right Juan. And uh,
it's kind of like a, the way you, when
you first learned how to jerk off, like,
you know, you just try and
dat, Dat, dat, Dat, dat.
It's the same fucking thing except he
threw it on the high end. But anyways,
there's a point in the story that
maybe you guys can relate to this,
the most fucked up podcasts,
um,
that I've done is he then played the song
about the ladies at some fucking song
about women set them free and quit fucking
around with them or whatever the hell
it is. Where is it? I downloaded the song,
but this is sick ass fucking Phil.
Okay.
Towards the end of the song. And, uh,
my drum teacher showed it to me.
You know,
if it goes over the bar line comes out
on the end of one. It's fucking unreal.
And who is it? Who is it
on drums? Phil Collins.
Yeah.
And I go,
you gotta be kidding me?
People on my podcast is shitting
on Phil Collins talking about,
you know how we sucks this sad look at
Gronk. He's down a fuck. This is bad.
They keep saying how he sucks in all
that, you know, and he was going, you,
we talk about, this guy's a fucking
monster. Hear this shit. He didn't, uh,
was it brand x? Oh No, we got
hit right in the fucking knee.
Um, all of that type of stuff. Um,
Oh God, that's bad our guys,
I'm sorry I'm watching them.
I'll never do this again.
This is like fucking ridiculous that
I'm doing this at the same time.
Um,
but anyways,
I'm covering my eyes cause I don't want
to fucking see his leg knee wiggle like
that again. This is, this is
why people hate Phil Collins.
Okay.
All right.
It's because they don't take the
time to act like this is a guy.
He's such a fucking
talent that he actually
yeah,
blank and he could go to Berkeley,
play drums.
I mean I know he's had health problems
but at the height of his popularity and
the height of his skills,
I should say before he got hurt,
like that guy could fucking force health.
I'm looking at Gronk for, for his
health got fucked up. I'm sorry guys.
This fucking guy would have like,
like musicians at Barkley with their
jaws on the fucking ground. All right.
And they're into all his prog rock shit.
But then he was so good,
he could actually fucking write songs
that made 14 year old girls dance around
like Molly Ringwald and breakfast club.
And the problem is,
is your average jackass,
classy bronco fans clapping right there,
class act right there.
The fucking year average jackass
isn't going to listen to the,
to the prog rock stuff.
So all they're going to
listen to his studio and all
that. I remember in the 80s,
I fucking hated Phil Collins. Mid
Eighties. I couldn't stand the guy.
And then when I started playing drums
and I started paying attention to who was
drawing on what, I was like, wow,
this guy dropped on the tears for fear
things. He drums for this in the 80s.
Robert Plant,
Eric Clapton Zeplin got together,
he played with them.
Um, if he really, I don't think that
they would be bringing this guy along.
What'd Ya? So I would say listen
to, uh, some of his oldest shit.
That's all I'm saying. I, you know what,
I'm going to put a clip up of
him just fucking playing, uh,
just playing drums and uh,
people probably still say that he sucks,
but I think he's the
shit. Um, but anyways, um,
can I bail now guys? Can I just
say that? That's the podcasts.
I'm sorry I didn't have the fucking
materials I need it, but I got a, uh,
I got an early day tomorrow.
I'm starting to get ready hyping
the F is for family by the way.
I'm getting great feedback on that. And
uh, I just wish it would come out already.
And uh, we got a premiere
coming up out here in la,
which I'm really excited and nervous
about. Um, is this weird feeling
when you watch something that you did
and it's being shown on a screen and you
can't fix it and it's
just going to be played.
It freaks me the fuck out because I'm
used to performing live and if it's going
Shitty, I can speed up, I
can slow down this, this,
I can make at least try
to make some adjustments.
But like if you're in something and
it's not working with the crowd,
you just got to sit there and
write it out. And um, you know,
it's a, it's a helpless feeling.
So I'm excited about that night,
but I'm also nervous, but I'm going
to be coming back east to do some, uh,
to do some press and then I come out
here and do a few more than I go to the
premiere. But, uh, once again,
it comes out December 18th. Uh,
also as I mentioned,
thank you to everybody who went
and bought Felicia Collins new,
a blues album off of
iTunes. Uh, what else?
They would want to have all of the
great stocking stuffer for 2015.
His tickets to the, uh, the fourth
annual Patrice O'neil comedy benefit,
um, that's going to be going
down Tuesday, January 26.
Did I say go and down? I
think I did. You know why?
Cause I was trying to focus on what I
was saying here and not the fact that we
just had a punt. The fucking ball
away again, um, makes a great gift.
It's obviously in remembrance of,
um,
one of the great friends I
ever had in life. And, uh,
I was talking to his mom the other
day and it reminded me of, uh,
so fucking Patrice O'Neal story.
He called me up one time, right.
This is back when we were both still
living at home with our parents.
Yeah.
And I pick up the phone, he's like, Bill,
he goes, what are you doing as like,
I'm not doing anything? He goes,
yeah, let's go up to the, uh,
the square one mall.
Yeah.
And I'm like, all right, where's that?
And he's like, it's up near Saga,
sub near the, uh, the cow loon.
And um, I go, all right,
why the fuck would I go? What do we have
to go up there for it? He goes, well,
you know, they, they,
I, I need to get a mop.
Okay,
I got you needed a mopey goes. Yeah.
And granted, this fucking mall is like,
dislike three miles between where
Patrice lived and where I lived.
And he wants to go all the way out of
his fucking way to go up to this God damn
mouth.
Okay.
And I like what the fuck kind of mall
but kind of mop do they have at this
square one mall and he's like,
oh he goes one of them square
one mall mops motherfucker.
And he starts flipping out
on me. So I go, all right.
I just finally got it out of him.
He wanted to go up there cause it was
right when they first put cheese in the
fucking crushed a pizza and
he wanted to try it out.
He started laughing when I finally
got it out, he goes, I got to try it.
I got to see what it's all about.
So we drove up in the
middle of the fucking day,
sitting in traffic on route one to buy a
fucking mop and so he could try stuffed
crust pizza.
I don't know why I told you that.
I'm just trying,
I'm trying to fill up the fucking
hour here. If I'd done an hour,
is it mercifully over g? You guys
saw my Kryptonite right here, man.
If I don't fucking,
yeah,
if I don't have any questions,
what do I do for that last half an hour?
I have no idea.
In order to realize is how few people
email me and give a fuck everything on
there was just bullshit about uh,
it was either spam or it was
shit about a f is for family,
one of the other, you got to do
this, you got to do that or a,
it's just a bunch of horse shit.
I,
I I thought I could scroll
through a couple pages.
I could find something I guess cause you
guys send them to the other email and I
don't even know how to get to it. Oh,
is that what you think bill? All right.
That's been the Monday morning podcast.
This is a completely fucked up one.
I apologize profusely for
this awful free podcast.
All right.
Before you guys start blogging about
it and you're telling me that you're
offended. Um, anyways, hey,
if anybody sees that movie creed,
let me know if it's good enough cause
I actually want to see that. Uh,
on two levels. One, uh, I'm a big
fan of Sylvester Stallone and to,
uh, I need to get back in shape. So I
figured whoever's playing, you know,
still owns always in shape. Even it's
70 fucking 70. He's still in shape. Oh,
how about the fucking Bruins, by
the way, when in five in a row?
Is that what happened? I think they
did. All right. That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves. Uh, Pete
Corey, Ellie this Thursday,
and thank you once again to a Joe Rogan
for me on the Joe Rogan experience to
help me promote the F is for family.
I really appreciate it. All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.